hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well through chapters
49 to 63 so that's quite a lot of
material in the mobo gym what what in
some is doing is finally getting at one
of the key goals of the work which is to
demonstrate their to be a Trinity along
the lines of that you know traditional
and christian doctrine within the divine
substance so that there is a unity and a
Trinity at the same time and the way
that the an Psalm is going to go about
explaining this is one that's not you
know completely original to him it's
actually in many respects rather
traditional itself and it's relying upon
a discussion of the faculties that was
already found in Augustine's on the
Trinity targeting the terms of memory
understanding and love you might say
well those aren't the only things that
the mind does but those are pretty
important and Anselm actually begins
this whole line of discussion by saying
that memory and understanding are
useless actually very useless unless the
thing that is being under
to it or remembered is loved or rejected
according to how reason dictates so you
know since the father and the son are
both you know supreme wisdom supreme
reason the you know he's already said
that the father can be identified with
memory the son with understanding the
question then is well are they going to
love and in some cells that pretty
quickly in chapter 14 Idol Supreme
Spirit loves himself he says he says as
I consider with the light the
distinguishing characteristics and the
common features the Father the Son I
find nothing that brings me greater
delight to consider that they're a
faction of mutual law and that's part of
what i'm trying to diagram here it's not
completely adequate but but it's the
best that we can do in two dimensions i
think he says it would be absurd to deny
that the Supreme Spirit loves himself
just as he remembers and understands
himself those where even when even the
rational mind you'd be shown to love
itself and him in virtue of the fact
that I can remember and understand
itself and him so he says the Supreme
Spirit loves himself just as he
remembers it understands himself when
God considers God God loves God and
loves God just as intensely as he or
just as fully as he remembers or
understands so in chapter 50 ants on his
way to say this love proceeds equally
from the Father the Son what does he
mean there he says anyone who has reason
it's perfectly clear to me does not
remember understand himself because he
loves himself rather he loves himself
because he remembers and understands
himself nothing is loved unless it's
remembered and understood and many
things I remembered and understood that
are not loved so it's evident he says
that the love of the Supreme Spirit
proceeds from him in virtue of the fact
that he remembers and understands
himself and we can say this bowl of the
father and of the son the father
remembers
through the son understands himself so
there's a relation on self love their
the son also loves himself but they also
love each other and handsome in chapter
51 says exactly that he says each loves
himself and the other with an equal love
so it's not like first there's the self
law and then there's the love for the
others all happening at the same time
all this crisscrossing of love which is
all happening within the same divine
spirit or the same divine essence of
divine substance right so he says if the
Supreme Spirit loves himself undoubtedly
the father loves himself the son loves
himself and each laws the other because
the father individually is the Supreme
Spirit and the Sun individually is the
Supreme Spirit both together are one
spirit and also because equally each
equally remembers and understands
himself and the other so it's not as if
these things are completely separate
from each other it's by virtue of being
what they are and being in the relation
that they are that all of this loving
comes into being or rather that it
doesn't really come into being it just
is what it is now here's where it gets
really interesting chapter 52 so far all
we've got is loving back and forth and
that's wonderful that it's nice that the
supreme you know being in the father of
the son loves itself and long as each
other one big love fest what's the
ontological status of that love is that
love something that you could say is
just an expression of the relationship
between them like the fact that one is
the father was the son the relationship
of generation we might call it or is the
love itself as an some suggesting itself
the Supreme Spirit the divine essence
the divine substance well if we remember
the relationship between the Father the
Son and how they're both the unity and
also the essence
each other and some that said that the
father is not going to bring into you
know it is every to bear or generate the
Sun as being anything less than the
father likewise this love between them
is in fact the Supreme Spirit just as
much as they are so here we have a
relation which itself becomes or rather
that's not even the right language which
reveals itself as having always been all
along the same thing that these are this
is how we're going to get the
traditional Trinity of father son and
spirit so let's take a look at an Psalms
reasoning it says how great that is this
love of the Supreme Spirit which is thus
coming to the Father the Son in his love
of himself is as great as his memory and
his memory and understanding of himself
as as great as its essence this can't be
otherwise that his love is indeed as
great as he himself is so this allows
the and some in chapter 53 to conclude
this love is the very same thing that
the Supreme Spirit is yet together with
father and son it is one spirit so he
says this love is the Supreme Spirit
even if no creature that is nothing
other than the Supreme Spirit ever
existed the father and son would
nevertheless love both themselves and
each other so it follows he says that
this love is nothing other than what the
Father the Son are namely the supreme
essence what is more necessary than that
the father and son in the love of each
is one supreme essence so we have again
a unity of the divine substance
expressed in
that three persons that are distinct
from each other right off the bat and
that only afterwards come to have
relations but three persons that are
intimately connected with each other
through the very relations and the law
of the holy spirit is that between the
father and son and itself so he goes on
and argues you know for example that
that it precedes throughout as a whole
from the father as a whole from the Sun
but is still only one love it because
it's a unity it's not their son as a
matter of fact that the language of
beginning and begotten doesn't really
apply here it's neither begotten or
running begotten it's a neutral you
could say and then he goes on and argues
you know about how this as long as the
Supreme Spirit fits in with both of them
I'm going to actually skip over quite a
bit of this because what we're really
interested in here is whether Anselm has
derived for himself some sort of
philosophical exposition of the Trinity
and by using this line of thinking about
it which he suggests is actually coming
from considering the divine substance he
seems to have have attained that so
we're going to skip ahead all the way to
chapter 63 how in one how in him there
is only one of one since certainly the
Father the Son of their spirits are not
three who utter even though each one of
them individually utters nor is there
more than one thing uttered with each
other's himself and the other two he
goes on and on with this and he says
it's established that just as knowledge
and understanding belong to his essence
even so is knowing and understanding of
nothing other than this is utter and
going further exists we can recognize
when the three of them are uttered
expressed whether by themselves or one
another
is not the case that more than one thing
is utter because what is uttered except
for their essence their essentia they're
being so if that essence is only one
that which is honored is only one and an
some is going to come go on and say I
see and this something wonderful and
inexplicable although it's evident that
each of them that is the father the son
of the spirit of the Father of the Son
equally utters himself and the other two
and there is only one word there
nevertheless it appears that the work
and in no way be called the word of all
three but only of one of them and so he
says there's only one father not several
father's one son met several sons and
one preceding spirit not several exists
in the Supreme essence so although they
are three in such a way that the father
is never the Sun or the preceding
preceding spirit the Sun is never the
father of the spirit and the spirit is
of the father of the son is never the
father wore the Sun although each
individually is so complete that he
needs no one nevertheless that which
they are is so much one that just as it
cannot be said of the plural of each of
them individually it cannot be said in
the plural of the three of them together
so we're we've got here is an some
penetrating as far as he can is he's not
simply you know giving us a
philosophical exposition the Trinity
that claims that now I'm cleared up all
the mystery of it it's still rather
mysterious it's still paradoxical but
he's managed to penetrate into that
mystery to a certain extent and he has
done so by stressing you know the Holy
Spirit as proceeding from the father and
the son through them up there love
itself is so much love is so much being
is so much wisdom is so much everything
else that it is a distinct third person
in relation to them and so what we have
here is an sums derivation of the
Christian Trinity by focusing
on love and focusing on it in relation
to memory and understand